in this video I'm going to show you how
to graph the sine the cosine the tangent
the secant the cosecant the cotangent is
designed to be a complete guide so let's
start at the beginning it will start
simple and we'll get a little bit more
challenging as we go through this video
I'll also have time stamps in the
description below if you want to jump to
a particular section of the video so the
first thing we want to talk about are
how to graph the basic sine graph and
cosine graph and then we're gonna get
into the transformation shifting
stretching compressing etc we're also
going to reference the unit circle and
I'm gonna show you where these graphs
come from so starting with the sine
graph we're gonna graph y equals sine of
X and if we go to a unit circle remember
the when you want to find the sine value
you look at the y coordinate of the
point on that unit circle so when we
think about sine we say okay the sine of
0 degrees or in this case 0 radians
either one you can see the sine value is
going to be 0 so I'm going to put a
point right here at 0 now at 45 degrees
okay it's root 2 over 2 and 90 degrees
it's 0 comma 1 so at 90 degrees you can
see the sine value is going to be 1 so
I'm just gonna write PI over 2 or 90
degrees the Y value of the output this
is going to be 1 at 180 degrees or PI
the Y value is 0 so I'm going to put a
point here at 0 at 3 PI over 2
ok our 270 the Y value is negative 1 so
we put a point down here at negative 1
and then at 2 pi we're back where we
started which the Y value is 0 so this
is your basic sine graph and you want to
memorize this basic shape this is going
to help you as you go on to do more
challenging problems so it's I think of
it as starting at this midline it goes
up to the maximum back to the midline
down to the minimum and then back to the
midline and then it starts over and it
keeps repeating like that you've got a
Maxima at 1 a minimum at negative 1 now
what happens if you wanted to graph y
equals 2 times sine of X well this
number that comes in front this is what
we call our amplitude a and that's going
to be a vertical stretch of 2 so what
happens is instead of going up to 1 now
you're gonna go up to 2 instead of going
down to negative 1 you're going to go
down
- negative - and so again that's just a
vertical stretch but it's still going to
cross the x-axis at those same points so
now see if we want to go to a slightly
more challenging problem sailing number
three we have y equals sine of 2x this
number here okay this is B value the
letter that comes or the variable or the
constant I should say that comes before
the variable ax that B value affects the
period and we can use this formula
period equals to PI over B to find out
what that new period is so in this case
the B value is 2 if we take 2 pi divided
by 2 that's just going to be PI so our
period is going to be PI what I like to
do is I kind of like to mark the x-axis
the scale first if the period is PI I'm
going to divide it up into four pieces
just so we did here one two three four
so pi divided by four gives us our scale
that's gonna be PI over four to PI over
4 3 PI over 4 4 PI over 4 okay so 2 PI
over 4 and 3 PI over 4 and 4 PI over 4
is PI we can see that the amplitude is 1
because 1 times anything is itself so it
hasn't been stretched vertically at all
and we haven't talked about the shifts
yet that's the h and the K that's gonna
pick up the graph move it left and right
up and down so here we can see that the
graph is just gonna have this basic
shape again it starts at the midline it
goes up to the maximum which is one back
to the midline back down to the minimum
which is negative one back to the
midline the only thing that was
different here is that the period
changed it was two pi divided by two
which is pi notice though that this
number here it has the opposite effect
on the graph instead of multiplying X's
by two we actually divided the X's by
two normally the period for sine and
cosine of two pi here it would divided
X's by two new period was just 1 pi so
let's keep going so let's go to number
four here now we're getting into y
equals sine of X plus PI minus 2 so here
you can see that the B value is 1 so
which means that our period is 2 pi
divided by 1 which is just 2 pi so let's
go ahead and Mark our scale here at 2 pi
divided up into four pieces one two
three four if you take two pi divided by
four that comes out to two PI over four
which reduces to PI over 2 to PI over 2
which is PI 3 PI over 2 4 PI over 2 so
I'm just taking this PI over 2
by two or by 3 or by four and that's how
I'm getting the scale on the x-axis the
amplitude is 1 so it's not being
stretched vertically at all so that
means it's gonna go up to a maximum of 1
and down to a minimum negative 1 but the
number this group with the ax that's
going to shift the graph in the X
direction it has the opposite effect
so plus pi is actually in a shift the
graph left pi okay negative pi and then
the minus 2 has the same effect that's
gonna be a vertical shift the minus 2 is
actually gonna shift it the same down to
okay as the sine so what's gonna happen
here is we can think of this graph is
shifting left pi now notice how our
scale is PI over 2 so it's a shift left
PI that's actually like shifting left 2
steps 1 2 so here over here at negative
PI and we're shifting down 2 so that's
gonna be 1/2 so that we can think of
this point right here is like our new
origin like our new starting point okay
so I kind of drew like a new y axis and
a new x axis and so what I'm going to do
now is I'm just gonna graph from here so
I'm starting at the midline I go up to
the maximum which we said was gonna be
you know 1 okay because it's not being
stretched at all back to the midline
back to the minimum and then back to the
midline so that's our basic graph the
only thing we did is we shifted
everything left to and down to and we
thought of that as our new starting
point okay let's talk about cosine we're
gonna get into some more challenging
examples involving the amplitude
changing the period changing as well as
a phase shift left and right and a
vertical shift up and down but let's
talk a little bit about cosine first so
when we talk about cosine we go to our
unit circle the cosine we're talking
about the x coordinates when we find
that cosine value so cosine of 0 degrees
or 0 radians is going to be 1 so with
cosine at 0 we start at 1 at PI over 2
or 90 degrees the x coordinate is 0 so
we go back down to 0 at PI which is here
at 180 degrees the cosine is x
coordinates negative 1 and then at 3 PI
over 2 the x coordinate is 0 and then at
2 pi you're back to where you started
the cosine is x coordinate you're back
to
one so you can see our basic cosine
graph has that basic shape like that it
starts at the maximum it goes to the
midline down to the minimum back to the
midline and then back up to the maximum
and then it repeats okay so these are
called sinusoidal graphs they have like
that S shape so now what would the graph
look like if you had y equals negative
cosine of X well the negative what it
does is it reflects the graph over the x
axis so all the X values are going to be
I'm sorry all the Y the hell is gonna be
the opposites the X values are gonna be
the same so instead of being at 1
they're gonna be at negative 1 0 times
negative 1 is still 0 negative 1 times
negative 1 is positive 1 0 times
negative 1 is 0 and 1 times negative 1
its negative 1 again we're just
reflecting it so this graph is gonna
look something like this dotted line
here it's just been flipped again you
want to memorize the basic shape so
cosine has that basic shape sine has
this basic shape and let's go to number
7 now y equals cosine of 1/2 X so just
like sine we look at that B value that
number that comes just in front of her
to the left of the variable X and we can
see that that B value is 1/2 if we want
to find the period we just say Q B
divided by B which is 1/2 when you
divide by a fraction it's really like
multiplying by the reciprocal so instead
of multiplying dividing by 1/2 I'm
multiply by 2 over 1 which gives us a
period of 4 pi so what I like to do is I
like to mark my x-axis with the period 4
pi and I divide it up into 4 pieces just
like the four quadrants 1 2 3 4 so our
scale is going to be pi then times 2 is
2 pi and then times 3 is 3 PI 4 PI so
just took 4 pi divided by 4 and that's
what I'm counting by to get to each
successive point on the x-axis our
amplitude is 1 because 1 times anything
is itself and we know cosine has that
basic shape where it starts at the
maximum back to the midline down to the
minimum back to the midline and then
back to the maximum and that's your
basic graph the only thing that changed
here was instead of dividing X's by 2 we
actually did the opposite we multiply
the XS by 2 that's why our period is 4
pi instead of the normal period of 2 pi
so let's go to number 8 now we've got y
equals cosine of X
- PI over 2 plus 1 you can see the
amplitude is 1 the period is going to be
the same 2 pi because 2 pi divided by
the B value here is 1 it's just going to
be 2 pi but what's happening is a graph
is shifting right PI over 2 remember the
one group of the X has the opposite
effect - PI over 2 you're actually going
to write PI over 2 and then plus 1 is
gonna shift up 1 so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just going to label my x-axis to PI
divided up into 4 pieces that's going to
be PI over 2 pi 3 PI over 2 and 2 pi and
we can see we haven't it's not being
stretched at all in the vertical
direction but what's happening is we're
shifting right PI over 2 up 1 we can
think of that as a new starting point or
like our new origin okay it's a cosine
graph remember the cosine starts at the
maximum so you're gonna start up here
you're gonna go back to the midline down
to the minimum back to the midline and
then back to the maximum so that's your
basic graph right there now notice the
amplitude is 1 so from that starting
point that's why it went up 1 and then
the minimum I went down 1 from the
midline and again you have that basic
shape it had a normal period of 2 pi it
was just everything was being shifted
right PI over 2 and up 1 let me erase
the whiteboard I've got some more
challenging problems involving all of
the different components a B H and K
let's look at those next and then we'll
jump into graphing the cosecant the
secant and then the tangent the
cotangent okay number nine let's look at
y equals 3 sine of 1/2 X minus PI minus
2 so we've got a little bit of
everything in this problem the first
thing I like to do though is I like to
look at the scale on the x axis the
horizontal stretch or compress so let's
figure out what the period is we've got
the B value of 1/2 so 2 pi divided by
1/2 looks like let's see so 2 pi divided
by 1/2 we know when we divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so that's going to be like 2
pi times 2 over 1 which is 4 pi so we're
gonna go ahead and Mark our scale we've
got 4 pi divide that by 4 we get 1 pi 2
pi 3 PI 4 PI but you can see that the
graph is shifting left pi I'm sorry - pi
is actually having the opposite effect
it's shifting right pi
and then down to so we can think of this
as our new starting point right PI down
to and that's that's your point right
there now you can see the amplitude is 3
so that's a vertical stretch of 3 and so
and we know we have a sine graph so we
can see that from this point it's going
to start here it's going to go up 3 so
let's see when you're over here you're
gonna go up 3 1 2 3 that's the maximum
back to the midline then down to the
minimum 1 2 3 which is gonna be right
down here and then back to the midline
and you've got one period of your sine
graph again notice that the one that's
grouped with the ax that's going to be
the phase shift it's gonna have the
opposite effect on minus pi shifts right
pi this is your vertical shift ur came
out it's shifting down to think of that
as your starting point pay attention to
the whether it's a sine graph or a
cosine graph and then the amplitude is a
vertical stretch so think of it as your
new starting point science starts at
that that origin goes up to the maximum
but that maximum is going to be 3 units
from that midline same thing with the
minimum it's going to be 3 units from
the midline and you've got it so let's
look at another example of involving all
the different components here number 10
y equals 2 times cosine of the quantity
4x plus pi plus 1 now what's different
about this problem is see how there's a
4 okay this B value it's inside of the
parenthesis it's grouped with the ax
what we need to do is we need to factor
it out and when you factor it at the 4
out you're gonna have to factor it out
of both of these terms so we're dividing
out 4 so our equation is going to look
like this now y equals 2 times cosine of
4x plus PI over 4 notice if you
distribute that 4 back in you get 4x
plus 4 PI over 4 which is 1 pi so that's
the key you definitely want to have just
one X inside of the parentheses so you
have to factor out that coefficient so
you can see here that the B value is 4
so if we take 2 pi divided by 4 that
reduces to PI over 2 so that's our hour
period PI over 2 if we divide that by 4
or multiply by 1/4 either way you're
going to get PI over 8 that's our scale
so 1 PI over 2 PI over 8 3 PI over 8 4
PI over 8 we can see that our graph
the shifting left pi over 4 because
remember this has the opposite effect on
the graph so it's going to go left PI
over 4 so PI over 4 is actually two
steps so left PI over 4 because PI over
8 times 2 is 2 PI over 8 which is PI
over 4 and then plus 1 it's going to
shift up 1 so that's our new starting
point we can think of that as our new
y-axis our new x-axis or new origin
it's a cosine graph with an amplitude of
2 so from here it's going to start at
the maximum so I'm going up to back to
the midline down to the minimum so
that's going to be down to back to the
midline and then back to the maximum up
to so that's going to be our basic
cosine shape the only difference is that
it's being stretched it's also being
shifted and the period is changing as
well so that was a good example so now
what we're gonna do is we're going to
transition over to working with the
secant and the cosecant graphs so just a
quick refresher when you think about the
cosecant it's really the reciprocal of
the sine graph see 1 over sine and when
you think of the secant a function it's
the reciprocal of the cosine ok function
so 1 over cosine so we're going to use
that information to graph these graphs
so when we look at y equals 2 secant of
X we can think of this as 2 over cosine
of X now let's start a little bit
simpler let's just say we wanted to
graph y equals not cosine of X but 1
over cosine of X which is equal to
secant of X so let's look at our basic
values on the unit circle so when we
think of cosine we said cosine starts at
the maximum it goes to the midline then
to the minimum dent in the midline back
to the maximum that's the basic shape
right this is 1 this is negative 1 this
is PI over 2 pi 3 PI over 2 and 2 pi
right but here's the thing when you're
at 0 see how the cosine value is 1 so if
this is equal to 1 right here 1 divided
by 1 is still 1 right when you're over
here at 0 PI over 2 see this is 0 what's
1 divided by 0
well that's undefined you can't divide
by 0 so what happens is we get a
vertical asymptote here
when you're at PI cosine is equal to
negative one what's one divided by
negative one that's still negative one
and then when you're over here at 3 PI
over 2 that's 0 again 1 divided by 0 is
undefined you get another vertical
asymptotes wherever the graph is
crossing the x-axis that's where your
vertical asymptotes are going to be now
notice when I'm at this point say for
example right here say for example this
is like a cosine value of 1/2 well 1
divided by 1/2 when you divide by a
fraction slike multiplied by the
reciprocal so 1 divided by 1/2 is really
going to be like two you're up here so
you can see this graph is looking like
this now when you're over here let's say
like that when cosine is negative 1/2 1
divided by negative 1/2 is going to be
like negative 2 right so this graph is
looking something like this
etc so what you can see is the coasts
cosine graph if you graph that and you
look at these key points where it
reaches a maximum or a minimum that's
going to be where the secant graph bends
or turns okay so I'll show you another
example so say for example this one y
equals 2 secant of X what you would do
is you would start by graphing y equals
2 cosine of X so cosine of X looks like
this it has an amplitude of 2 okay has a
period of 2 pi like that wherever it
crosses the x-axis those are where our
asymptotes are going to be and then the
secant graph is going to have the shape
where it goes the opposite direction
like that okay and again the reason it
works is because see how when this value
is let's say for example 1 well then you
have 2/1 which is actually going to be 2
right and then same thing over here when
this is like 1/2 2 divided by 1/2 that's
going to be 4 so you can see that as
this gets smaller and smaller the cosine
graph the seeking graph section here
it's going to be larger and larger
because when you divide by a small and
smaller fraction you're multiplied by
the reciprocal this is going to go up
and up and up so that's the same idea
when you're looking with the cosecant
graph remember cosecant is the
reciprocal of sine so if we wanted to
graph this graph let's just graph y
equals 3 sine of PI over 4 times X the
sine graph we know looks like this ok
the amplitude is 3
so it's gonna reach a maximum here at
negative three and I'm positive three
and down to negative three wherever it
crosses the x-axis that's where our
vertical asymptotes are okay sometimes
when you're doing this secant and
cosecant graphs that helps to draw you
know a little bit more cycles okay more
periods and then what you can do now is
you can say our graph is going to look
like this now the one thing that I
haven't done yet is look at the period
so let me do that on last year usually I
do it before I graph this but I would
take the PI over 4 remember the period
is 2 pi divided by PI over 4 okay 2 pi
divided by B which is like multiplying
by the reciprocal so the PI's cancel and
it's actually going to have a period of
8 so you can see this is going to be
right here it's going to be 8 divided up
into 4 pieces 2 4 6 8 that's our scale
and you've got your cosecant graph okay
let's do a little more challenging one
number 13 we've got y equals 4 secant
1/4 X plus 2 pi minus 1 so that's a lot
right but what we're gonna do first is
we're gonna graph the same equation here
except for instead of secant we're gonna
think of it as cosine okay if we take
the period 2pi divided by b which is 2pi
divided by 1/4 when you divide by 1/4
it's like multiplied by the reciprocal
that's going to be 8 pi so our period is
going to be 8 pi here divide it into 4
pieces that's gonna be 2 pi 4 PI 6 pi 8
pi okay but the graph is shifting left 2
pi down 1 so we're gonna think of this
as our like our new origin like right
like that okay and the amplitude is 4
it's a cosine graph so we're going to go
up 4 so this is going to be 1 2 3 4 so
it's going to start right here it's
going to go back down to the midline
okay and then it's going to go down to
the minimum which is going to be right
here at down 4 from the midline then
back to the midline and then back to the
maximum okay which is 4 above the
midline because the amplitude here is 4
so that's going to be your basic C your
basic graph something like that okay and
it's going to continue okay but what we
need to pay attention to is
this cosine graph crosses the midline
okay so it's crossing basically like
this so it's crossing right here it's
crossing right here okay
it's crossing right here etc so our
secant graphs actually going to look
like this it's going to approach the
asymptotes but it's not going to cross
them or touch them so that's the basic
idea and you've got it so let me erase
the whiteboard we're going to talk about
tangent and cotangent next okay now
switching gears over to tangent and
cotangent when you graph tangent we're
going to be using the values from
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
and remember from the unit circle the
tangents the Y value divided by the x
value so let's just go ahead and graph
the basic parent graph first and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to start
over here at negative PI over 2 and
tangent is Y divided by X now negative 1
divided by 0 we can't divide by zero
that's undefined so we're gonna get a
vertical asymptote right here at
negative PI over 2 now at negative PI
over 4 tangents Y over X anything
divided by itself is 1 but we have a
negative divided by positive which is
negative 1 so over here at negative PI
over 4 this is going to be right here at
negative 1 at 0 Y divided by X is 0
divided by 1 is going to be 0 so that's
gonna be another key point at PI over 4
which is 45 degrees tangent is y over X
of course anything divided by itself is
going to be 1 and then at PI over 2
tangent is y over X 1 over 0 we can't
divide by zero that's undefined we get
another vertical asymptote so that's one
period and what's interesting about
tangent as opposed to sine and cosine is
that the period is 1 pi divided by B
naught 2 pi divided by B so you can see
that from negative PI over 2 to positive
PI over 2 this is actually a period of
pi and then what happens is this graphs
going to repeat like that same thing
over on this side as well and just going
to keep repeating like that but just 1
period one cycle from negative PI over 2
to positive PI over 2 but for number 15
what do you think this 2 does to the
graph
well you can see the two is this
coefficient in front here and it's going
to be like a vertical stretch if it's
greater than one or a vertical shrink if
it's between zero and one of course if
it's negative that's going to reflect it
over the x-axis so if I was to graph a
number 15 on the same graph what would
happen is two times zero is still zero
one times two is going to give us two
and negative 1 times 2 is going to give
us negative two so what would happen
here is the graph would actually be
something like that where it's being
stretched it's going up faster two times
faster okay for number 16 we've got y
equals tangent of 1/2 X what do you
think the 1/2 dust of the graph well you
can see that this number here is in
front of our variable ax that's our B
value pi divided by 1/2 remember when
you divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so that
means that this is period is actually
going to be not 1/2 but actually doubled
it's actually gonna be 2 pi now when you
graph a tangent an important thing to
realize is that see how half the graph
is to the left of the y-axis and half
the graph is to the right so when you
figure out what the period is like in
this case we've figured out the period
is 2 pi I'm gonna cut that period in
half so 1/2 of 2 pi is going to be 1 pi
and I'm gonna put negative pi so from
negative pi to pi that's actually a
period of 2 pi right so I'm going to go
ahead and sketch in our asymptotes okay
just as dotted lines and then what I
like to do is I like to cut this in half
again so half of Pi is going to be PI
over 2 some people call these like the
halfway points or the midway points and
negative PI over 2 ok so now what we're
gonna do is you can see that this
coefficient in front of the tangents
just 1 so we're just going to be going
at these halfway points up to 1 and then
down to negative 1 and it goes right
here through the origin and we've got a
good sketch of our graph so remember the
one that's grouped with the ax actually
has the opposite effect it looks like
we're dividing by two we're actually
multiplying the X values by two and
that's stretching it horizontally let's
look at another another example number
17 this one has more going on here the
first thing I like to do is figure out
what the period is so I would look at
that coefficient that B value I'd say
well let's see pi divided by 2 that's PI
over 2 but again because half's on the
left and half on the
right side of the y-axis what we're
gonna do is we're going to cut it in
half again making this PI over 4 and
negative PI over 4 which gives us a
period of PI over 2 you can cut it in
half again PI over 8 and negative PI
over 8 and then now let's look at the
phase shift okay the left and right and
the vertical shift up and down so the
number of this group with the ax
remember this has the opposite effect
the minus PI over 8 is actually going to
shift it to the right PI over 8 okay
pause and PI over 8 and this one has the
same effect the pulse one's gonna shift
it up 1 but what am i doing this one a
little bit different than some of the
other problems that I've done in this
video is let's just graph what the
original graph would look like without
the shift so we would have asymptotes
right here okay like this and like this
but now what's going to happen is it's
going to go up here to one it's going to
go down here to negative one and through
the origin but what the PI over 8 is
going to do is going to shift it right
PI over 8 so each of these points is
going to move right PI over 8 and then
up one so this point would go right here
and right here
this point is gonna go right an up one
and this point is gonna go right and up
one like that so now you can see our
graph is looking something like this
okay and where our asymptote was here at
negative PI over 4 is now I'm going to
shift right PI over 8 so it's going to
be right here and the one that was over
here at PI over 4 is now going to be one
step over here at 3 PI over 8 and so now
you've got your your tangent graph so it
shifted right PI over 8 up one okay now
let's take a look at cotangent so when
you think about cotangent you're
thinking on the unit circle that's
actually the x-coordinate divided by the
y-coordinate and the unit circle values
we're going to use for cotangent are
from zero to pi okay zero to 180 so
cotangent of zero is going to be 1 over
0 which is undefined so right here at
zero we're gonna have an asymptote
okay vertical asymptote at PI over 4 X
divided by Y is going to be 1 because
anything divided by itself is 1 and then
over here at PI over 2 X divided by y 0
divided by 1 is going to be 0
okay and then over at 3 PI over 4 X
divided by Y is going to be negative 1
and then over here at PI X divided by Y
negative 1 divided by 0 is undefined so
we get another vertical asymptote like
that so you can see the graph is going
down to the right ok
whereas with tangent it was going up to
the right and the other interesting
thing again is that the tangent half of
the graph is to the left of the y-axis
1/2 is to the right unless it's been
shifted whereas with cotangent you can
see that that whole graph is to the
right of the y-axis okay
but again the graph repeats so there's
going to be another branch over here ok
another branch over here like that and
it's going to keep repeating but for one
period one cycle from 0 to pi to the
right of the y axis going down to the
right is your basic graph also get a
couple more challenging cotangent graphs
ok for number 19 we have y equals 3
cotangent PI over 2 times X so first
thing I like to do is to figure out what
the period is using this formula so for
tangent and cotangent we're going to be
using the period equals pi divided by B
for sine cosine secant and cosecant it's
two pi divided by B so if we do PI
divided by PI over 2 that's really the
same as pi times 2 over pi because when
you divide by a fraction you're
multiplying by the reciprocal notice the
PI's cancel and we get a period of two
so there's no pi in the period they're
just two so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna label this as two and if I divide
this by four cutting it up into four
pieces that's going to be one half one
and one and a half okay and so now you
can see our asymptotes are gonna be
right here at two and zero okay just
like our parent function right here okay
hasn't been shifted at all but what does
the three do to the graph well the three
is going to be a vertical stretch so
this point here which is normally at one
is now going to be at three so right
there
crosses at the midline here and then
this point here which is only a negative
one is going to be multiplied by three
it can be a negative 3 1 2 negative 3 so
you can see this was just a vertical
stretch and then the period had changed
using the PI over 2 so let's look at
number 20 now a little bit more
challenging still we've got y
negative cotangent 1/4 the quantity X
minus pi minus 1 okay so there's a lot
involved in this one the negative is
going to reflect it over the x axis
that's going to make the Y value is the
opposite sign right but let's figure out
what our period is I always do that
first so I do pi divided by B now the B
is 1/4 but when you divide by a 1/4 it's
like multiplied by the reciprocal so
it's actually gonna be 4 pi so let's
label this 4 pi let's divide it up into
4 pieces 1 pi 2 pi 3 PI 4 PI and then
now let's see so normally cotangent is
going down to the right right but the
negative is going to reflect it so now
it's going to be going up to the right
so let's kind of just draw our basic
graph here we're to do it in two steps
so normally a cotangent would be here
it's gonna reflect it's gonna be down
here at negative 1 crosses at the
midline and then it goes up to positive
1 and then you have your other
asymptotes like that so this would be
your graph like that right but now what
happens here the minus Pyatt and the
minus 1 well this is actually had the
opposite effect it's actually going to
go right pi then the minus 1 is going to
go down 1 so we go right pi at this
point and down 1 okay that's going to be
right here this point is going to be
right pi and down 1 right here and right
pi and down 1 right here now the up and
down isn't gonna affect the vertical
asymptotes but the right pi is so
normally the asymptotes here it's gonna
go right pi so now it's going to be
right here and then the one that was at
4 pi is now gonna be here at 5 pi and so
now you can see there's your cotangent
graph so if you're enjoying these videos
subscribe to the channel my channel is
all about making learning math less
stressful so you can raise your grade
pass your class and go on to pursue your
dreams I look forward to helping in the
future videos
I'll talk to you soon